we'll be will take place it is organized
by the foundation of peace and the
UNESCO Secretariat Russian Foreign
Minister Sergey Lavrov will participate
in the opening ceremony among the key
topics the interaction between science
and civil society science in today's
world and organizers hope that prominent
scientists both national and foreign
experts and professors eminent medical
experts from about 100 countries will
attend the meeting on the 26th of
November the Minister for natha's Sergei
Lavrov who will meet the special
representative of the OSCE to
Transnistria they will exchange views on
the topics included in the meeting of
the OSI ministers of Foreign Affairs on
Transnistrian settlement and other
issues of mutual interest between the
26th and 28th of November the Minister
of Foreign Affairs of the Dominican
Republic will command a working visit to
Russia on the 26th of November the
ministers of the two countries will
exchange views on a wide range of issues
of the bilateral agenda with the
emphasis on boosting political dialogue
trade and economic cultural and
humanitarian ties them special attention
will be paid to the problems of
international and the original character
and the prospects of interaction on
multilateral venues primarily the UN
India of the election of the Dominican
Republic non permanent member of the
United Nations Security Council for 2019
the visit of the Minister of Foreign
Affairs of the Dominican Republic marks
a new stage over intensive development
of the bilateral ties and proves that
the cooperation between Russia and Latin
America Latin America and the Caribbean
countries being expanded on the 27th of
November Sergei Lavrov will come on a
working visit to France the agenda
includes talks with the Minister of
Europe and foreign affairs of the French
Republic and the participation of the
two ministers in the China dialogue
meeting of the coordination Council in
versal the will speak about the pressing
issues of the bilateral cooperation
including the meeting of the Council for
economic financial industrial and the
trade issues scheduled for the 17th of
December and they will discuss cultural
and humanitarian projects as well the
ministers will exchange views on such
important international issues as the
situation in Syria Libya Yemen and
prospects over settling the Ukrainian
conflict preserving the joint
comprehensive plan of action on Iran's
nuclear deal the future of the NF Treaty
the issues of fostering and boosting
European security and the preparation
procedures for the meeting of foreign
ministers of the OSE countries the
ministers will participate in the
meeting of the Trianon dialogue of the
coordination council of the russian
french s civil society's forum and we'll
discuss the measures to boost the direct
contacts between Russian people and
French people to foster the friendly
relations between the countries between
the 27th and 28th of November Sergei
Lavrov will be in Switzerland on a
working visit and they participate in
the Geneva ministerial
France on Afghanistan and the UN ages
the event will address the issues of the
International assistance to national
reconciliation process in Afghanistan
the review of the implementation of the
reform program by the government of the
country and support for original
economic initiatives and mechanisms for
Afghanistan the conference will be
attended by the representatives over 70
countries and the 28 national
organizations and on the 28th of
November the Minister of Foreign Affairs
Sergey Lavrov or we'll have talks with
the had with the Minister of Foreign
Affairs of Switzerland and you're in the
meeting that will discuss pressing
issues over bilateral relations and
national issues that are over a mutual
interest we have already said that
Sergey Lavrov will come to Italy to
participate in the fourth international
conference that is called Mediterranean
the dialog in Rome the data are
published on the official website of the
Minister of Foreign Affairs and I would
like to say that today about 3 p.m.
Moscow time the text of the interview
Sergei Lavrov has given a to the Italian
Information Agency Archie will be
published and you will be able to read
it on the official website of the
Russian Ministry of Foreign Affairs and
now we turn to our the important
developments and we'll start with the
situation around maria butanna always to
follow closely the situation and i will
remind you that the american authorities
have
I've been holding Murray boutonniere in
custody and the far-fetched accusations
and the diplomats of our embassy regular
visit Murray Bettina and now she is
paying much attention to examining the
the necessary material and that will
take place on the 19th of December and
we will take all possible steps to
release Maria Bettina so as possible
because Maria has fallen victim to the
Riza phobic sentiments in Washington and
the character of the accusations against
her shows that she is a political
prisoner now we turn to the situation
around Syria over the past week the
situation in Syria was table with the
several trouble spots in areas where
terrorists allocated we're still
concerned by the situation in a
northwestern part of the country in
Italy and last - awakened the horas
addeen militants affiliated with
al-qaeda conducted a major raid and
attacked the post of Syrian government
forces in the area over a Geron and 18
servicemen died repelling the attack
such deadly provocations show that is PI
the serious efforts taken by the Turkish
side to implement the joint memorandum
dated the 17th of September there are
still difficult is to preserve the
Demilitarized Zone in aid Lib
or we closely cooperate with the Turkish
partners as we know the other day mr.
shoigu discussed the difficult situation
in a live with the Turkish colleague him
we're still concerned by the actions
taken by the US and the aircrafts of the
coalition have long been delivering
intensive and not targeted attacks
against the city of Hajj in
and many citizens and many civilians
were killed last week we spoke about 50
corpses that have been found not to the
south of Hajin and last weekend 40
people died including women and children
acontece the information of the Syrian
mass media the evasion of the coalition
once again used a white phosphorus
shells
McCarron super sister reject that like
in April when they said that the Syrian
government used to chemical weapons in
duma though they did not provide any
evidence to that Washington that has
deployed the troops illegally on the
Syrian territory for political ated
reasons and with no time limits shows
that it is not interested in solving the
crisis as soon as possible and hampers
the efforts to ensure economic
restoration and the return of refugees
and internally displaced persons and
another example of that was the
publication on the 20th of November and
by the Ministry of Finance of the United
States on imposing severe restrictions
against two Russian companies that were
suspected in supplying oil products to
Syria circumventing the unilateral
American central sanctions and
Washington threatened that that would be
the case with everyone who would violate
the sanction regimes
imposed by the US it turns out that the
Americans would like to leave Syrians
tired of war without the necessary
resource such as fuel and what about the
protection of human rights
because the coalition led by the United
States tried to help civilians and that
is the real help they provide to them
some positive moments so the other day
the Syrian army Journal stuff stated
that the military operation on restoring
control over the al-safa Plato has been
finished the territory with a difficult
terrain of 380 square kilometers has
been liberated from terrorists and
Russia still continues to provide help
to return Syrian refugees and internally
displaced persons and now the number of
refugees returning to Syria stands at
one thousand people a day Syrian
authorities claimed that 195 thousand
families returned to the Deir Ezzor
province the Syrian authorities restore
the social and economic infrastructure
and redouble efforts to ensure the
dignified conditions for example in the
Latakia province about 400 out over 1500
houses have been restored between the
28th and 29th of November Astana will
host 11th international meeting on Syria
and the Astana format where the
representatives of Russia Iran and
Turkey will exchange views on the
situation in Syria and the settlement in
the country in general and the meeting
will discuss the prac
questions as usual one of the sore spots
in the in Syria is ribbon a camp for
internally displaced persons where tens
of thousands of people still live in
very dire very difficult conditions we
speak about that regularly Russian
diplomats and military experts the
representatives of the Ministry of one
of us speak about the troop the camp is
situated in the area that has been
illegally occupied by the US it is the
Alton province a large American military
base is set supposedly in order to fight
against Isis and deter Iran is located
on the sovereign territory of the UN
member state on the border between Syria
Iraq and Jordan extremists of all
stripes feel at ease in the area and in
early November the UN structures with
the consent of Syrian authorities and
active cooperation of the Russian side
provided humanitarian aid to the Red
Bank help necessary consultations have
been held with the u.s. to ensure a
successful passage of the convoy but at
the same time as is customary the
American side took liberties with the
arrangements in particularly the
obligations on ensuring the security of
the convoy inside the US controlled zone
were transferred not to one of the
illegal armed units and the
representatives of the Syrian Red
Crescent Society were denied access to
the camp and we deem it inadmissible the
situation in the camp is becoming worse
and worse the Syrians who leave them are
in difficult conditions they have no
food normal normal food they have
at Shenzhen little medical aid rubbish
isn't removed there is no huge system
crime and violence are rampant children
are recruited to the illegal armed units
and is indicative that the entry and
exit limited this should be paid full
and it's possible only if there is a
special permit for that it would be
great if several major news agencies and
media outlets make reports about the
developments in ribbon that should be
true that should be true story about the
ribbon camp without attempts to justify
the efforts taken by the u.s. in the
camp now turning to the another
international issue we are heavily
concerned about the adoption
during the one of the meetings of the
OPCW that was held in Hague about the
increasing budget for 2019 by 2.5
million euros that would go to the
attribution this is a legal term now
I'll explain it to you first of all
according to the budget document of the
organization submitted to
director-general of the Technical
Secretariat I highlight here the bird
technical secretary now this body is
given a general legitimate right to
define wood maybe even to a point those
responsible in financing terrorist acts
terrorist attacks with the use of
chemical weapons
Sencha decision can be made
independently against an individual
organization or even certain state in
the case of individual organization here
is speak about the direct intervention
of the OPCW into the internal affairs of
member states and technical body is
given itself rights that might be used
only by the Security Council of the UN
so this is about the direct interference
into the prerogatives of this
international organ and practically
about the collapse of the system of
international relations established
after the Second World War as we have
repeatedly said this decision can take
at all one of the convention of the
prohibition of chemical weapons and
we've repeatedly said that this decision
runs counter this convention I would
like to remind that according to the
Monty it's given to the Technical
Secretariat of the OPCW this technical
body might only investigate incident
center make conclusions with chemical
agents agents were used or not at least
it acted like this before and under the
current budget it is planned that the
Secretariat will focus on defining
responsibles in this Middle East country
but nowadays we don't quite know
modalities and methods of the berik of
the organization the special group on
attribution was created
to adopt the decision that is useful for
a narrow group of countries and their
concern is raised and this concern is
legitimate that there is a danger that
the principle of impunity and the use of
chemical weapons might be eroded we
support such principle but nowadays it
can be used for the interests of narrow
group of countries and even for the use
of force in violation of the norms of
the Security Council and we and that was
proved in 2018 when in 2017 when three
Western countries attacked Syria
violating in this kind of the
international law I would like to remind
that the attribute if budget is voted
with ninety nine votes and it was
succeeded with the political and
financial pressure on certain countries
the OPCW is well aware about this and we
recreate that countries that had
balanced position once nowadays didn't
didn't couldn't oppose this provocative
idea of Western countries blackmailing
and ultimate ultimate mates now become a
calling card Washington London and Paris
and the results of voting in the OPCW
demonstrated that not all countries of
this organization
an arbitrary approach of Western
countries this decision about
attribution has an any irreparable
damage into the OPCW and it only
aggravates the divide between member
countries of these ones a successful
organization that is really divided on
serious differences on Syrian case
prefabricated crippled case and now on
attribution as well together with our
allies and like-minded countries we will
oppose such a destructive line and
direction that is aimed at that a aimed
at erosion the basis of international
law and multilateral treaties on this
venus we will clarify in detail and
using arguments about the harmfulness of
of trying to use the serious topic in
political aims we I would like to series
retrospectively how it was done in
history and we have a lot of such
examples and these examples are relevant
in today's international context for
instance on the 29th 30th November in
the conference of humanitarian law the
150th anniversary of the Sun features
particular Asian renouncing to use in
time of war of explosive projectiles
will be celebrated and this event can be
perceived as a simple historical time
date important for experts but I believe
that
this day is very important today in the
context of modern international
relations international organizations
and our partners they always give us
examples of the series of our actions
that proves the illegitimate nature of
actions our hostile approach and
violation of international law that
which is not true but we can now base
ourselves on facts so the document that
I mentioned was initiated by Russia and
it marked a very important stage in the
development of international law and
this is the first document that limited
the development of new types of weapons
and this was the first time that the
question of the use of such weapons was
perceived not only from the point of
your fees were feasibility but also from
the position of humanism a declaration
was adopted following the international
conference that was convened in October
9 118 78 in st. Petersburg want an
initiative of militant that led the
ministry of defense of Russian of the
Russian Empire so this is a very
important moment and the first country
that rejected the invitation of the
Russian government to take part in the
conference was the United States and the
archives prove that British
representative wanted that declaration
contained in note that it's legally
binding only for those countries who
signed it and the declaration
voules its validity and it's legally
binding nature only in the case if one
country that is participating in the war
with two counterparties doesn't attach
the decoration so it is very important
to highlight the fact that Russia wanted
to limit this vile violent weapon and it
was supported and developed by a group
of countries they decide they suggested
to extend the action of the declaration
to all armaments that could be called
barbaric and now the UK gets into the
game and it's supported in general
Russian suggestions but it claimed that
the its forces are not so numerous there
is a need to fill this gap with
scientific achievements and
modernizations in the military sphere
and the International Water Filter
Martens comment in the position of
praetor said that and these grounds
England cannot deprive itself at its own
detriment of the resources that it owes
to the ingenuity of its people after the
conference of 1868 in Saint Petersburg
Russia suggested that new conferences
can be held in Brussels
74 and in Hague in 99 and in all seven
in the 20th century and our colleagues
from toss and together with the in with
a I CC prepared create media project
dedicated to the event where the history
of the creation of document is vividly
described there are a lot of photos and
the link to this presentation to this
material will be given to you of course
another important date in the end of
November we celebrate the 45th
anniversary of the beginning of the
involvement of Russia in peacekeeping
during operation so I remind your own 25
of November 1947 in Cairo
first officers from Russia work even the
blue helmets blow Barretts that's how
the glorious history of our
participation in peacekeeping operation
started in March 1992
the Supreme Soviet of the Russian
Federation made a decision to send the
first Russian military units to
participate in UN peacekeeping operation
these recent years our contingents have
participated in missions in different
countries in DPR in Colombian Cyprus in
South Sudan in the Middle East and
caused event in West Sahara the great
experience of our experts in
peacekeeping and the law of the rule of
law the urchins the
the healthcare and the salvation of
people in emergencies is in demand is
still in demand and I would like to add
that through the permanent represent a
permanent mission to the UN in New York
number of events is planned we've turned
a reef attached to the attention of mrs.
McGarry nee to the problem of the sea of
azov and we examined it her declaration
that was made following the EU Council
or foreign affairs meeting in Brussels
on day nine 19th of November and we saw
her response to a question posed by
media on the situation in the Sea of
Azov first of all we don't quite
understand the logic of selectively
fortune claims against illegitimate
actions of Russian feature of the
Russian Federation and as of in the sea
of azov and we don't know if whether the
European Union has a clear position when
a forcible seizure of the Russian fusion
board
Nord by Ukraine on the 25th of March and
ports at the position of Ukraine remains
a secret so the members of crew of the
board vertice have been detained for
more than six months by Ukrainian
authorities on trumped-up charges and
her care and its captain that is
situated in Ukraine now faces the risk
of imprisonment in this situation we
have a logical question to what extent
the you you
here for Human Rights out with the
conjecture interests and we would like
to highlight that we should speak about
professional exchange of views supported
by statistical data and precise facts
and not on human later signals by the
European Union as stated by federica
mogherini to media and journalists and
the public opinion the sense of our
position is that the Russian Federation
is committed to the provisions of the
agreements between Russian Federation
and Ukraine on cooperation in the use of
the CFA's event the courage straight
according to this Agreement Russian boar
board guards have the right to inspect
important the sea of elephant in the
church Street for a number of reasons
according to the law according to the
statics that statistics that is recent
9-month the general number of verified
boats under the flag of Russian
Federation have been growing it is very
important to note that vessels damaged
before the passage of the Strait of
gauge in Ukrainian ports are not
connected to board control this is that
a kind of question this navigation
regime in case unical canal is depends
on specific breeds of sizes of canal and
difficult material and navigational
conditions
that's root quest a lot of time because
of the need of pilotage for example and
now it is the main part of vessels are
checked not in the area of the sea but
when they were weighted Stern to pass
through the cursed Street these kinds of
the regime of passage of the gauge
cynical Canal is not new it's existed
before the construction of the Crimean
bridge when it was controlled by Russia
this trade and our turn we are concerned
about the fact that the Ukrainian
authorities intentionally stirred up
tensions in region using the guise of
militarization of the AFC Kyiv boasts
the creation of its naval base in pure
junks and intends to involve neither
potential in the region
EU partners should bear in mind that
this behavior of Kiev can take a toll on
the situation in the region and on
prevention measures to guarantee the
security of Russian citizens and objects
of strategic infrastructure and as we
know we've received threats not only
from Ukrainian radical forces and
marginalized elements but also from the
politicians of this state the arguments
were brought to the notice of the EU
repeatedly during negotiations and
meetings and the last time it was done
during very consultation of state
secretary Vice Minister of the foreign
of Foreign Affairs of the Russian
Federation mr. krei
sin and secretary-general of European
external Action Service Helga Schmidt
and Brussels want in 19th of November or
the 15th of November we have the
impression that fall in these contexts
we were able to accommodate your
concerns to consolidate this
understanding we've reached the
agreement that will synchronize our
watches periodically about the situation
with navigation in the SFC given what I
have already said it is a very it is
very dangerous to a trauma ties the
situation in region we don't know
anything about the intentions of the
European Commission and we proceed from
the fact that the actions of the you
will be responsible and transparent they
will they will not run counter
international law and principles of
European security would and by the way
we already did this but it would be nice
and I would recommend to our partners in
Brussels to take a look at the recently
published book by a red Slav Sikorski
let me remind he is the foreign head of
the Foreign Ministry of Poland the book
is called Tolan can be better an
intimate history of Poland it would be
interesting for our Western partners and
all those who want to understand what
exactly happened in Ukraine and how it
could be qualified from the point of
view of international law in particular
mr. Sikorski unravels the real side of
the Western policy and politics against
Russia and shows the mechanics of the
events that took place in the recent
years in Ukraine in particular
he says that the polish Swedish child
project the Eastern Partnership of the
European Union was originally created to
establish the anti-russian so-called
protection over Ukraine which in the end
resulted in a maidan coup d'etat these
are not our estimations these are the
sayings of the foreign form a foreign
minister of poland
he also says how polish diplomacy tried
to draw a wedge between Moscow and Minsk
this is also an interesting topic all
the things that we talked about in our
estimations of the West's destructive
actions all of this is confirmed in the
book the West was always trying to
convince us otherwise but still such
books are published and they confirm
everything that we talked about it is
most regrettable that mr. Sikorski
became so frank only after his
resignation we also took note of the
sayings of the foreign minister of czech
here in particular in an interview to a
Czech newspaper he supposed that
Russians could use the occasion of the
50th anniversary of the Prague Spring in
Czechoslovakia to apologize for the
events of 1968 I would like to remind
the head of the Czech Foreign Ministry
who was only appointed recently of the
one of the founding documents of Russia
shock relations namely the agreement on
friendly relations cooperation between
the Russian Federation and the Czech
Republic of the 26th of August 1993 the
preamble of this agreement
mansions the desire of decides to
finally put an end to the totalitarian
past related with the unacceptable use
of force against Czechoslovakia in 1968
and the further unjustified presence of
Soviet forces on the Czechoslovakian
territory such positions was later
reaffirmed by the highest authorities of
our country the declarations in the
interview concerning Russia's foreign
policy and his vision of the cooperation
within our country contrast and go
against the Czech declared intentions to
cooperate with Russia and develop friend
relations in the interests of our
citizens on the basis of therefore
mentioned treaty in our bilateral
relations with Czech here we would like
to proceed from such constructive
prospects another topic we would like to
make a comment on the repatriation of
internally displaced persons from
Bangladesh to Myanmar in spite of the 15
November deadline the return to
reinstate of the displaced persons
located in Bangladesh the agreements
reached at the end of last month between
Daka and a pedo the two capitals remain
unemployment 'add those agreements
implying the practical settlement of the
problem including its humanitarian
aspects we have information that the
refusal of the first group of
repatriates to come back to myanmar was
the result of pressure and threats of
physical lynching by the extremist
elements present in the refugee camps in
Cox's Bazar region including extremist
from the so called Archon Salvation Army
let me remind you that this organization
is directly responsible for the
escalation of the situation in the
aforementioned
refined state in 2016-2017 which
provoked a mass exodus from Rakhine of
muslims and representatives of other
religious confessions it is apparent
that the actions of the radical
extremists are aimed at artificial
escalation of the crisis around the
Rakhine State and the Muslims who live
there to create a pretext to continue
for external pressure against the
government of Myanmar and interference
into the internal affairs of this
country we're concerned by the fact that
such plans are being played along by the
representative of Western countries and
international organizations who say that
there are no conditions for a safe
repatriation there's an impression that
certain external forces have their own
agenda the true goals of which are far
from the careful interests of displaced
persons who've been in the temporary
camps for a long time their goals are
aim to prolong the conflict situation in
and around a rock Hinde state in our
turn we welcome the firm efforts of
Bangladesh and Yanmar to continue direct
dialogue to settle the humanitarian
crisis and the readiness of the
countries to continue discussions of the
repatriation of the displaced persons
we hope that constructive cooperation
with the office of the High Commissioner
of the UN for Refugees and the UN
Development Programme will continue in
accordance with the previously reached
agreements we consider it important to
launch the process of repatriation while
taking the steps by the international
community to improve the conditions for
their repatriates and to protect the
rights of all ethical and confessional
communities in the region the questions
that we received from different media
outlets on expert visits to the
hello Guerra Center in Georgia we took
note of the Rivas Lee announced visit on
the 14th 15th of November of a certain
international group of experts to the
Grove Georgia in international Public
Health Center it is worth noting that
the healthcare minister of Georgia
stated to journalists before the event
that its goal was to confirm the things
that we already know the transparency
and adherence to international
conventions this is exactly what
happened according to the Georgian media
the international experts supposedly
reaffirmed the peaceful and transparent
nature of the centrist activity but as
revealed later the only official
document which contained all these
optimistic conclusions is a message on
the website of the Lagarde Center itself
the message was not signed it contains
no names of foreign experts or the names
of Contras and organizations that they
represented the so called document
emphasizes that all the employees of the
center confirmed to these unnamed
experts the exclusively peaceful nature
of their activities perhaps after this
the guests did not want to find out why
the peaceful Georgian health care center
housed the US Army Medical Research
Facility and what research exactly was
carried out by the US Army we still
await explanations from Washington and
belizean the true nature of the activity
of the lugar center and such
introductory visits of course do not
clarify the situation receive numerous
questions on the elections of the new
president of Interpol on this occasion
we would like to answer these questions
the pre-election days were accompanied
by the massive disinformation
and pressure unleashed by the United
States against the rush
candidate to this post in the
anti-russian sentiment Washington
renounced its approaches to not disclose
its preferences during international
organization elections and used the
State Department to oppose the election
of the Russian representative in fact
let's say it has it was it was a blatant
interference into the internal affairs
of an independent international
organization which considers itself
depoliticized which is solely
professional community such actions are
unacceptable they damage the reputation
and the authority of Interpol at the
same time we would like to express our
gratitude to the states which in spite
of the open pressure supported the
professionalism and experience of the
Russian representative we also took note
of the foreign security policy strategy
for 2019 2020 adopted by the Danish
government on the 15th of November this
document which intends to state the
exact initiative and focal points of the
Danish foreign policy in the near future
focuses on the measures to counter the
aggressive actions of Russia in the fact
that our country ranks first among all
the existing threats to the security of
Denmark he is an example and an
explanation of the anti-russian
sentiments in Copenhagen while the true
transnational challenges like
international terrorism drug traffic
climate change do not concern the Danish
strategists it seems that the current
Danish political establishment
favors the momentary political interests
and sacrifices the traditionally good
Russian Danish relations such an
constructive actions deprive us of the
opportunity to solve the existing
problems the new speculations on the
so-called Russian threat were needed by
hoping Copenhagen to justify the
increase of the defense budget and
building up the military presence of
NATO in the Baltic Sea region this
military scenario will not contribute to
regional security the same rather
similar notes are heard in Norway we
took note or the recent statements of
the defense minister of this state who
once again accused Russia of creating
certain interference to the GPS
navigation signals supposedly
aggravating the work of civil aviation
in the north of the country a number of
Western politicians have become
accustomed to accuse Russia of any
incidents without providing any proof
and not requesting our comments and our
position keeping in mind the
unprecedented openness of the Russian
Federation in the military area our
military partners in Norway could
receive competent answers to all the
relevant questions but the Norwegian
public and the Norwegian media let me
say this once again no official requests
were made although they could have done
so and received all the answers they
needed there is an impression that such
stories were needed by the Norwegian
defence ministry to distract the public
opinion from the unraveling scandal for
example with the newest frigate of the
Norway Navy Helge Ingstad which crashed
on the 8th of November with an oil
tanker
and result in its sinking at the
outskirts of Bergen according to the
International automated identification
system the frigate carrying rocket
weapons who had its transponder turned
off its course crossed with the path of
the tanker that's why they did not see
it following the crash the transponder
was turned on which allowed to identify
its exact location this incident could
be seen as ridiculous if not for the
catastrophic ecological and
environmental consequences of the leak
of 60,000 tons of oil on the tanker this
is a second recent incident on the
territory of Norway with serious
consequences for environmental security
previously this month the public learned
about the facts of inappropriate storage
of radioactive waste in the main
national storage of Norway in him darlin
fifty kilometres of Oslo by the way the
recent NATO exercise on the territory of
Norway apart from the Helge Ingstad
incident or marked by a number of other
dangerous incidents so now some facts
let us move on from the anti-russian
phat fakes to the verified data on the
17th of october following a hard landing
of the anti-submarine helicopter caimen
aboard the landing ship dick smith of
the french navy at least four people
were injured on the 22nd of october
following an incident on the ship gaston
hall of the u.s. navy several crew
members were injured the ship could not
continue participating in the exercise
on 26th of October the engineering room
of Gala facts frigate of the Canadian
Navy caught fire which was put out by
the crew on the 30th of October Toronto
frigate of the Canadian Navy had an
accident in the power generator and
about six hours it was adrift creating a
threat to navigation and the sea and on
the next day due to the failure of the
steering system it had to leave the
exercise we would like to know attend
authorities to think about the
prevention of such dangerous incidents
for the environment and security of the
nose perhaps Copenhagen could also think
about it instead of making new
strategies for its security and instead
of trying to make Russia responsible for
the irresponsible and incompetent
unprofessional actions and today on the
22nd of November the national museum of
the republic of tajikistan hosts an
opening ceremony of the exhibition
Russia and Tajikistan following the path
of friendship organized by the
administration of the President of the
Russian Federation the State Archives
the Russian embassy and our partners in
Tajikistan this event marks the 25th
anniversary of the treaty of friendship
and cooperation between the Russian
Federation and the Republic of
Tajikistan Tajikistan is one of the key
partners of Russia in the region and has
a special place in the foreign policy of
our country the detailed materials on
this topic and the upcoming event will
be available on the internet pages of
the foreign ministry and our embassy
[Music]
another thing on the 29th of November in
the centre of astronautics in north
eastern Slovenian an ally will be laid
to appraise mr. sagorsky and mr. Putin
ignored monk who are the pioneers of
theoretic astronautics
so these are mr. Sikorski a russian and
soviet scientist and
austrian-hungarian a rocket engineer a
mr. patoshik no longer amount the
honorable guests of the meeting the head
of the National Council which is the
upper chamber of the Slovenian
Parliament a cosmonaut hero of Russia
mr. Bajoran Russian ambassador to
Slovenia and the members of the
Slovenian Cabinet of Ministers the
representatives over the experts from
the Oblast
Kaluga Oblast will also participate the
center in the city of V Tanya which is
well known in Europe and Russia are
closely linked and the creation of this
Ally will contribute to further
extension of international links in the
sphere of high-technology ISM and I
would like to respond to the question
and that have been asked during the past
two briefings
it was the interaction with Iran in
financial sphere and there is another
event that happened when Iran has been
cut off the system Swift system
unfortunately we have to say that the
Brussels sir financial messaging service
swift a surrender to the legitimate
until Iran sanctions imposed by Trump's
administration in November and several
banks and credit organizations of Iran
including the central bank of the
country have been cut off the financial
message means his service we haven't
heard about the decision being sanctions
and authorized by the UN Security
Council
we're surprised by the inaction of the
European authorities that once again
didn't counter the extraterritorial use
of sanctions against the country and the
work of the financial body and the
Belgian jurisdiction as well the
cooperation between Russia and Iran in
the interbank in sphere it is being
conducted effectively and consistently
on the platform over the relevant
working group in the framework of the
bilateral working group on trade and
economic cooperation if we do not dig
into details I would like to mention
that Moscow and Tehran are working on
ensuring and safeguarding legal
legitimate trade and economic links and
projects that have been done long before
2015 general joint comprehensive plan of
action it standard risk management
procedures and work and we should ensure
the safe channels over financial
messaging and another important thing I
would like to say the new year
festivals and holidays coming and we
have published the information on the
official web site and on social networks
related to with a free regime for
Russian people going abroad to other
countries and I would like to draw the
attention of the mass media and the
general public
to these sites and to social media
because they will help you to plan your
holiday
we regularly update the information on
the website of consulates on the website
of the Russian Foreign Minister foreign
affairs and we have several times told
you about the special Crisis Management
Center that has been developed the
mobile application that is called the
assistant for those who go abroad which
contains recommendations in case of
emergency it can be downloaded to laptop
iPad a mobile phone and there is a
special alert button which can help you
to be in contact with others the
application provides the crime situation
in the country the level of terrorist
threat the procedures of accident entry
into this of that country and the data
are usually updated amber to answer your
questions if there are any a no sund of
a Moscow Baku Information Agency
Azerbaijan made an peacekeeping threat
step proposing to exchange your
prisoners of war with the mania and the
international working group planned such
a meeting but Amenia refused to conduct
that exchange and how can Moscow as the
co-chair of the Working Group can
comment that well we welcome all the
arrangements that follow the line of
conflict settlement but the arrangement
implies the consent of both parties and
the work on achieving this consent well
initiative is a good thing and but these
initiatives should be turned into
arrangements so they should be worked
upon in Milan during the meeting of the
OSI foreign ministers the leaders over
Mena and Azerbaijan the foreign
ministers of
zabba John I will meet is it possible
relevance again I can just repeat the
words I have already said let us expand
the contacts of the two parties and we
have welcomed another round of the
meeting if the sides they agree to have
such a meeting it's a sovereign right of
each and every state to conduct such
meetings and if the meeting is held if
it is constructive we can only welcome
it yes please good afternoon so many of
you re missionaries paper following the
Singapore summit since it will be
claimed that he agreed with Vladimir
Putin to sign an agreement a peace
agreement on the basis of the
declaration of 1956 and two of the Kuril
Islands will be given to Japan and as
Russia needs that is it possible well
many questions arise following the
summit and in relation to this issue let
us make a brief but detailed review on
the peace agreement as you know on the
14th of November the Prime Minister of
Japan and the Russian president agreed
to accelerate the process on the peace
agreement based on the declaration of
1956 the document is well known it's the
legal basis on which Russian Japanese
relations being built it was ratified by
the parliaments of the two countries and
it is it was deposited to the UN as
international treaty it was
the document that ensured the
restoration of political relations
between the two countries there were no
agreements on the peace treaty the peace
process is underway it is very difficult
and we should understand that the
results shouldn't run counter the
national interests of either Russia or
Japan the Declaration was signed in a
certain historical context but then
Japan refused to comply with the
agreement and well the situation in the
world differs from the context of 1956
it is important to understand how Tokyo
regards the declaration and the
exception over the results of the Second
World War
according to which the coral island are
possessed by Russia and we still do not
know what influence can be made if the
United States continues to exert
pressure on Japan and we understand that
important work is lying ahead to make
the relations between Japan and Russia
become more effective that would allow
us to solve all the issues between the
two countries yes please thank you maria
vladimirovna the ambassador of Syria
claimed that the President of Syria
Bashar al-assad was going to visit
Moscow can you provide us with the
details of the visit and another
question about Syria by late November it
was said that not around over the Istana
process will be held could you comment
on that well I have just comment
on the Istana format that is why I
believe that I can hardly make any
additions to that if we have some
additional information about that I will
share it with you as for the visits of
presidents of the heads of states of
Russia's presidents and summits this is
in the competence of the administration
of Russia's president we have noted that
several times yes please
maria babanova as with that channel
yesterday
James mattis claimed that the United
States hoped that Russia would
demonstrate the will to return to the
implementation of the Arnoff treaty and
that would be the most beneficial
approach what is Russia's position on
this issue we can only say that Moscow
expects Washington to respect the
international law in general as for the
accusations against Moscow in related to
the violations of the treaty we have
several times said that the information
was false it is disinformation and we
suggested that we start a meaningful
dialogue on that issue yes please
Finnish TV channel in Monday on Monday
finish Minister of Foreign Affairs
expressed concerns about the situation
related to the problems with the GPS
signal during NATO exercises in Norway
could you comment on that
and what will happen next
are they going to be discussions about
that well you see we have commented on
that by the embassies of Embassy of
Russia in Finland and you're in the
meetings in the Ministry of Foreign
Affairs of Finland the safety of flight
is very important for Russia as for
Finland and we noted that Russia hasn't
received any information about the fact
that the source of this noise are
located in Russia and we highlighted
that in order to examine the situation
on a professional level a practical
dialog should be conducted through the
relevant services of the countries of
the region and you have asked me about
the developments the future developments
well Russia has expressed its desire and
willing to conduct a dialog and ask any
questions but we are waiting for the
response from Finland no one refuses a
normal expedite the question is why do
we need to turn the practical
cooperation to the sphere Oh
megaphone diplomacy into the sphere over
far-fetched and trumped-up accusations
without providing facts if there are
facts
let us begin a serious dialogue let us
launch a serious dialogue if the facts
cannot can be provided to the public
well we agree to that
but still there should be facts and
there are no facts right now they're not
provided either by mass media or by
official channels today I have spoken
about similar accusations we hear from
Denmark
no way the situation is the same there
are no facts but there are accusations
and so the question about the future
developments should be addressed to the
representative of the Ministry of
Foreign Affairs of Finland Russia is
always ready to professional dialogue
Russia has a willing to conduct work in
such a format rather than to open a
newspaper to turn on a TV or to read in
Internet article and find the
far-fetched accusations without any
facts speak to the microphone please I'm
sorry you have a mic please use it for
everyone to hear you I would like to
give the floor to your colleague good
afternoon the Islamic radio I would like
to learn about several types of weapons
anti-personnel mines if for example
there was a state that was against the
use of such mines and and well what is
the question if it is still so the
United States is the only country that
is against the ban to anti-personnel
mines well thank you very much I will
now be the representative of the
American side probably right now
but there are the official bodies here
in Russia of the trep resent the
American side and there are people who
are ready to respond that this question
to reply to this question if you speak
globally then I will specify the number
of countries that support or oppose this
the use of anti-personnel mines but the
position of America should be commented
on by the Americans well it is just to
continue the topic about is a st.
Petersburg declaration well the second
thing thank you very much for a good
briefing about NATO moving eastward and
NATO's presence in European countries
but I would like to learn about the
diplomatic relations over the Soviet
Union with the NATO how could the Soviet
Union allow NATO to move east order that
happened in Reykjavik oh when the
causative was the head over the Minister
of Foreign Affairs and probably during
the last briefing I cited I the
interview or the statement of Mikhail
Gorbachev who stated that the assurances
that were given were violated by those
who had given them so in this case we
should speak about the fact that the
Western community and certain countries
and political systems that shaped the
entity and that develop eight
I did their utmost to mislead not only
the Soviet Union but the international
community in general it was a deceitful
action it was not the question of NATO
cooperating with another country it was
a global mystification because at that
moment if you recollect it layman
journalists politicians had great hopes
about the future they hoped that after
the confrontation of the bipolar world
after the confrontation of countries and
the military blocks during the Cold War
new times will come without the
dictatorship of one political system or
one club of countries but the world will
build relations on totally different
basis that will reckon with the
experience of the 20th century
including the Cold War and the two world
wars and that was why the negotiations
about disarmament have been held these
negotiations were conducted between the
United States and the Soviet Union and
in this case we should not speak about
the internal assessment over the then a
political leadership or of the United
States or the Soviet Union but rather
about the fact that it was
it was a lie the international community
was deceived yes please come Ranga son
of said grad channel the other day the
meeting on the sidelines of the General
Assembly was held in many countries I
supported the expansion over the
membership of the United Nations
Security Council I'm interested in the
permanent members of the UNSC as we know
there are five countries presented there
and three of them are NATO countries
there is China as well but it doesn't
always support our resolutions so Russia
is practically alone there do you
believe we it would be better to expand
the membership of the United Nations
Security Council to include Brazil and
India in this case we will strike the
balance well we can speak about that
hours and hours I can share with you
some information about that but there is
a certain material presented on the site
Sergey Lavrov also spoke about that if
we speak about it briefly because we do
not have an opportunity to speak about
that loads so the United Nations
Security Council and the reform of the
council if there will be one should
improve the work of the council and as a
result to make the world safer by
fostering by reinforcing the structure
that is responsible for the stability in
the
world it means that we should make it
more efficient rather than less
efficient and from this point of view
such an approach should be borne in mind
and realized there during the
implementation of the analytical review
of the reform procedure we should
remember that today the Security Council
which where the processes are sometimes
stalled because our partners try to push
the self-serving interests but as for
the reform of the council it should
result in making the body more efficient
rather than making it an efficient a
tool I will make a broad comment about
that yes please al-jazeera TV channel
marilla de merna how can you comment on
a new round of talks on a Yemen that is
scheduled for November in Sweden and how
can you assess the humanitarian
situation in Yemen we have provided the
broad assessment in Yemen at the past
the last briefing as for the talks we
proceed from the fact that any attempt
of the international community to
contribute the solution of this serious
crisis should be welcomed I cannot
comment on the results
the event will
happen in the future I'm sorry is Russia
going to participate in the meeting I
will specify it yes please al arabi
channel muhammad hasaan in on tuesday
the Minister of Defense of Turkey met
the minister of defense of Russia to
discuss the situation in aid lab has the
Russian position on a Lib
demilitarization as I own changed
no it wasn't we reaffirmed it yes please
cell division addition why the Russian
authorities
why did Russian authorities agreed to
have talks on the coral islands is it
somehow connected with the sanctions can
the two islands be given to Japan can
you repeat that without the telephone
why did Russian authorities agreed on
having talks with Japan on that issue on
the coral islands only now well it is
not so things you are saying are false
why is not so I cannot say that it is a
question to you why do you use false
data asking the question could you
comment on the meeting that took place
on the 14th of November attended by the
Russian president and the Japanese Prime
Minister well I have just mentioned that
what should I say
what Edition do you represent it is such
a vision I can provide the data to you I
will hand it to you Japanese side
promised not to set the u.s. military
base can or cannot be the excuse for
giving the two islands to Japan well is
it possible today different countries
violate the norms the national law the
agreements they do it instantly so what
can be said about words that only words
without any documents agreements
signatures unfortunately the leading
countries show bad example to others by
undermining the international law and if
some years ago the term of an agreement
at treaty an obligation were treated
seriously and it would serve as a
guarantee of preserving the position of
the development according to the course
the pre-planned course and today we see
that many countries violate obligations
thus making these agreements and
arrangements invalid can I ask another
question in 2016 Vladimir Putin said
that the Russian Federation doesn't give
the territories
that easily in an interview has the
position of the Russian Federation
changed well now we can hope we will
hope that the Kuril Islands will be
still a Russian well we will hope that
Russia will still stick to the position
voiced by Vladimir Putin in 2016 but the
question should be asked should be
posted to the administration of the
president good afternoon
you have now very serious concurrence
Donald Trump wanted to play on oil
prices how the Ministry of Foreign
Affairs could comment on this could
comment on the role in oil prices on the
one hand - the president of sovereign
country legitimately alleged by his
people has the right to make
declarations on policies of his country
and in this case I perceive it like that
but quote but in terms of energy
security that include that is included
into international agenda and can be
discussed you have another question this
week the MSU and more held events
dedicated to the answer page
it's how the Ministry of Foreign Affairs
assesses such activities in the
ex-soviet space we assess them as a
positive development of bilateral
cultural relations Anton Alexeyev is an
Estonian TV channel innovative now
you've commented on this two weeks ago I
mean the Global Compact on migration but
after two weeks different new countries
said that they will not join the compact
and as well as Israel have said the same
the government of Estonia is divided
over the question over the support of
this compact those countries who join
will join the compact do they risk that
they will that they will host refugees
our policy is in long term it's long
term policy and we we have not changed
our position since then in comparison to
other countries information again agency
red screen could you please comment on
the decoration of the cooperation
between the UK and Russia so you know
this is the question of the right of
sovereign countries who can't develop
their relations and different spheres in
military sphere as well but we proceed
from the fact that nowadays the real
purpose of international community that
is interested in result in the
resolution of the Ukrainian crisis and I
showed
the in this context the declaration
should aim at real in real resolution of
the conflict and if it is really so this
is one case but if we speak about
developing a military cooperation that
could have a negative impact on the
situation in the region of conflict in
Donbass off-key of course it raises
concerns could it please ask you another
question
Kazakhstan said that probably in Astana
they will discuss the possibility of new
observers trust in a format if we speak
about observers this is a normal
diplomatic process which is encouraged
but we don't speak nowadays about the
change of the format itself I reiterate
this is a normal question the question
about observers I mean she takes a watch
Iranian Information Agency evening I
have two questions the first question is
about sanctions against Russia the the
United States imposed sanctions on
Russia how
Oh put them yes this information is very
interesting and for any journalist for
example if 200 people are in this top
list unfortunately we will force to give
a mirror response sometimes a mirror one
sometimes a symmetrical one and I think
this does not matter much when it
concerns the sanctions imposed by the
United States against Russia and the
Russian officials the physical and legal
persons let me emphasize once again that
this was not our were a choice this was
a responsive reaction which is an
integral part of the current
international relations as for the
overall number of people in this top
list I do not have such statistics and
the banks or American companies what
they included in the sanction lists I
say once again that we took a response
measures sometimes mirror measures
sometimes not a symmetrical measures I
will get back to you on the facts and
the figures but let me say that as you
know we have never initiated a nice
thing like that neither against the
United States nor against other
countries we think this is an absolutely
legitimate position and policy and the
second question concerning the is
following yesterday Minister Lavrov in
Minsk said that Russia and Belarus are
deeply concerned about the building up
of the potential and the capacity of the
eastern flank of NATO this is is not a
quote but the overall idea so is there
anything expected in the future is
Russia for example going to deploy
modern missiles as mentioned by
President Putin and that for for example
if the United States withdraw from the
missile treaty I think this is a
question for the defense ministry thank
you we do not want to intimidate anyone
we want to take the international
community to take note of the fact that
in the system of international security
and strategic stability the United
States and their allies deliberately
damage the whole system this is not only
a matter of security of Russia this is a
matter of global affairs and this is a
matter of the future of the system of
international relations unfortunately we
see that we have absolutely opposite
positions as you said when the United
States try to intimidate others and
build up their capacity they do it in a
systematic way and they do this
following a certain paradigm at the same
time using their propaganda and this
information matters they accuse Russia
of certain aggressive steps
that's why aggression and the
manifestation of intimidation are not
the methods that the Russian Federation
uses this is not our choice Russia has
been through many wars many destructive
and violent conflicts on its territory
against our will these words were always
backed by many of the currently leading
global powers we're all aware we all
know of the Great Patriotic War the
world war and let me say that unlike
other countries these wars took place on
our own territory so there is no
intimidation there is no provocative
action especially aggressive ones in the
international ones Russia has never used
such tools we all understand well what
war means and may ask another question
about five years ago they
used the pretext that Iran was the
threat and now they do not say it runs
the threat no it runs still the threat
but they say that there are other actors
Iran is not as guilty as before
according to the yes they still say that
in this case the expansion of NATO and
building up of the European missile
defense system are justified by the
Iranian threat
I think Tehran and not only the
officials but also the public knows this
Russia has always denounced such
accusations against Iran against Iran in
general saying that any attempts to
explain the expansion of the missile
defense system and the construction of
new sites in Europe cannot be justified
by the Iranian threat there was a
conference in Moscow on this topic where
we said that we interpret the expansion
of NATO and the building of the missile
defense system in Europe as a threat to
the global stability and not as a matter
of certain bilateral concerns or
bilateral relations do you have any more
questions yes please
you raised a daily Information Agency
tea honesty Innova we had historical day
to day and I remember that yesterday
mark 23 years since the Dayton Accords
on Bosnia Herzegovina and we're on topic
who recently assumed the post of the
chair of the precedium of Bosnia
Herzegovina said in an interview to the
Serbian TV channel that he would
continue pursuing the elimination of the
high representative post for Bosnia and
Russia as one of the guarantors of the
Dayton Accords that's Russia think that
Bosnia is ready to think about this I
the Foreign Minister of the Russian
Federation has made numerous statements
on this topic I will send you the links
and update our position and share it
next time thank you thank you yes please
government all of federal news agency
the head of the Crimean Parliament
Latimer Constantin have declared that
the Ukrainian events may result in a new
my done he says that the signals that
are sent from Ukraine mean that the
country is moving towards the collapse
and we would witness it this could be
implemented as in you Maidan is the
foreign ministry expecting and in you
turbulences any in Ukraine and what
would Russia's at it should be do you
think they do not have any turbulence
now I think this is not a realistic a
attitude there are certain events will
destructive consequences for the future
of Ukraine they take place right now we
do not use any position of these
positions and we provide an objective
political evaluation of the national
policy of the country or rather the anti
policy we have provided our forecasts
and evaluations of the current religious
policy of Ukraine we've mentioned on
numerous occasions the problems with the
language law and many other phenomena in
the life of Ukraine these are all
manifestations of the turbulence which
is the result of the anti-constitutional
coup d'etat in the country I say goodbye
until next time thank you